okay part two of ogre next uh so i was
playing around a little bit more and
looking at more of these samples and
some of these samples are just so cool
and i didn't really realize it at the
time i was making
first one how cool some of these demos
were because i was basically looking at
the tutorials which are very basic
little things
but some of these are super neat
and they really show you the potential
of over next and what it has
ready to go for anyone that needs a
rendering system
this pretty much sells me on it all
right so let me just uh flip through
some of these here
it's gonna clack around with my keyboard
and just look at some of these so for
example
look at this animation tag point
and basically tells you a little bit
tells you about the animation system and
it has a little fly system so you can
look
fly around most of these have fly
controls in them
uh nothing's super impressive here it's
hard to see okay there he goes
he moved all right and that's just one
let's go to the next
this one is area approximate lights
it has some light planes and stuff going
on here
and as you can see you can toggle
animation and
the no texture thing okay
and then there's custom renderable
let's check this one out
not sure exactly what this is supposed
to show off but
as you can see the shadowing worked fine
okay decals
okay so it has f3
to hide show animated objects
there's some objects f4
show hide palette spheres there we go
we can toggle transparency mode
it's hard to see the difference on that
as you can see it's doing something with
i'm not sure i don't even understand
what's going on here but
basically changing them based on their
location and
stuff
dynamic geometry let's try that one out
like the samples in here are just super
cool there's just so
so many
got some changing geometry
forward 3d
well okay that's just my mouse wheel i
don't know what the heck mouse wheel's
doing but it's doing something crazy
uh okay let's go back to normal all
right
so this is playing around with lights we
can increase or decrease the number of
lights
and their radius
and change between clustered forward and
forward 3d
change the threshold
all sorts of things you can play around
with here wow
sample hdr
change the exposure
uh how do you change it back
okay well that's pretty cool effect
capabilities there
heavy overcast moon knight
well
there's another one hdr
smaa
change the time of day effect
threshold well i'm just blown away by
the number of examples
and cool little things that are in here
not entirely sure what this one is just
like lights up against so
dark wall i guess pretty cool
import animations share skeleton
instance let's see what this one looks
like
alrighty cool
of course source code is right there
instant stereo now i tried this one
before it kind of crashed my computer so
i'm not going to do the instant stereo
here's instant radiosity let's give that
one a look
and looks like there's a bunch of
different things we can change here the
bias
cluster size looks like it's
shift to lower it
on shift to tighten it
it doesn't really tell you that but i
kind of figured it out
number of rays
multiplier threshold
power boost
x range oh yeah i guess it does tell you
that hold shift to change in the
opposite direction
and you can change the light type with
f3 directional light
point lights and spotlights
load cube maps
not entirely sure what i'm looking at
here to be honest
just looks like more lights
load cue maps manual probes
i love these reflections they look super
nice
excuse me it's probably really that
adjust material roughness
the air a little bit and hold shift to
move faster
pretty cool morph animations let's check
out that
very cool pbs
materials
let's get real close to one of these
pixel grid placement
okay post processing
it actually gives us a little bit of a
scene which is kind of cool
skybox and everything and we can change
some effects
bloom radial blur
glass
dither old tv
[Music]
styling old movie
motion blur
and you can combine them up to glass in
blue
so this is one of the coolest ones i
think to play around with
check out refractions
scene format
[Music]
apparently i'm saving scenes
i'm sure i really understand i think
this is saving
i'm not really sure what it's doing but
it's doing something with the file there
green space reflections
and change the roughness
this one is destroying my frames
i mean only 30 frames
shadow map debugging
try that one out
change the filters
shadow map from code
static shadow maps
seems like the same code probably
something different though
stencil test
okay stereo rendering i'm going to skip
that one because i think i might
crash my stuff tutorial distortion all
right so now we're getting back into the
tutorials
i don't know where like the walkthrough
for these tutorials is
i couldn't find it but there it is some
distortion that looks cool
and change the strength
although my plus doesn't seem to work so
i can only turn it down
and we're getting into all the tutorials
here
which i think i showed a few of there's
terrain i want to look at terrain
very cool we can lock the camera to the
ground with that too
i noticed they don't lock the camera so
you can do like 360s
should be an easy fix surprise i didn't
fix that
you could change the time of day
my plus key doesn't work
run it again
walk to the ground
go up on this hill
and
change asthma let's see that doesn't do
anything
pretty cool though
okay i'm gonna skip some of these
tutorial ones maybe i'll look at
look at a few of them
if you're not already sold on ogre this
might
sell you on it it seems super cool uh
the next thing i'm probably going to do
is try to implement a minute into my own
project and use it
for my own little game because
i i can't imagine any of the other
renders i was looking at being better
than ogre and having more functionality
we already did that distortion one
multi-threading basics and
multi-threading let's just look at
look at that
okay so this is more about the code
it is what you're seeing on the screen i
think
and there's some vr stuff which i don't
think i'm going to
i don't know if this is vr
and this one's called updating decals
and area lights
let's check that out
cool
looks like we can just change all those
um
let's check out manual objects
interesting and mesh
going to the top
mesh if this is
okay just this guy again
so a lot of samples here a lot of cool
little things
and also you can if you're wondering
which ones you can run and you're not
sure
well basically all the samples you can
run but you can always tell by going to
the properties
and if it's an application you can run
it
if you go to the properties and it's a
dll or a utility
or static live you can't run it it's to
support
applications i'm sure you already know
that if you've gotten this far but maybe
don't
well what else can i even show
i think that's it all right well i
thought i'd just follow up and show you
some of the cool
examples that come with it in a video in
case you couldn't get this far or needed
motivation
keep going or something
there you go alright see you guys in the
next video peace out